let me make this very clear you are not
my family you are not my friend
in a shocking social media post Kim
calls Sarah Jessica a hypocrite writing
their continuous reaching out is a
painful reminder of how cool you really
were then and now so I'm writing to tell
you one last time to stop exploiting our
tragedy in order to restore your nice
girl persona the tragedy Kim's referring
to as her brother's recent death she
shared this shot of her and her late
sibling on Instagram to which Sarah
commented dearest Kim my love and
condolences to you and yours and
Godspeed to your beloved brother days
later while promoting her show divorce
Sarah continued to send condolences to
Kim while speaking with various media
outlets something her co-star clearly
did not appreciate the photo Kim posts
on Instagram says I don't need your love
or support at this tragic time Sarah
Jessica Parker in the caption she also
links to a page six story about the so
called Mean Girls culture that destroyed
Sex and the City
the article claims SJP and her co-stars
cynthia nixon and kristin davis ganged
up on kim with an insider claiming that
by the end of the show no one would talk
to her
what is your problem I don't have a
problem you have a problem The Sex and
the City stars have been back in the
tabloids ever since Kim said no to doing
a third film of the franchise while the
rest of the cast was reported the game
Kim told Piers Morgan on life stories
she had no interest intervening
have you never really got off we've
never been friends we've been colleagues
Sarah said she took Kim's cutting
remarks to heart while stopping buy a
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
I found it very upsetting because that's
you know that's not the way I recall our
experience today and he's defending his
good friend Sarah Jessica on his Sirius
XM show I also don't like it that people
are characterizing this as a catfight
there's only one person fighting here
SJP is divorced co-star Molly Shannon's
also vouching for the actress calling
her supportive and wonderful but
Morgan is siding with Kim tweeting 100%
behind Kim Cattrall on this nothing
worse than someone who's treated you
like dirt
suddenly pretending to care about you to
make themselves look good in the
public's eyes